hi there and thanks so much for watching
our video my name is bradley knapp and
i'm one of the product managers here at
ibm cloud and the question that i'm
answering for you today is what is an
mzr you're obviously on our site you're
seeing this mentioned a lot so what is
it m
z
r
well mzr is an acronym it stands for
multi-zone region and so before i can
answer what is a multi-zone region first
we need to talk about what is a zone or
specific to ibm cloud what is an
availability zone or an az
so
an availability zone is a single
physical location that contains all of
the infrastructure necessary to run
ibm's cloud so if we think about what
goes inside an az
let's imagine our building here right so
this is a physical data center building
well what do you need to run the cloud
obviously you've got to have some
internet that comes in right so you've
got fiber that's coming in from multiple
providers
multiple redundant 10 gigabit links and
so we'll have fiber that come in from
all of the major telcos because we need
to guarantee as much uptime as possible
also because you our clients need to be
able to tie in with us you want to come
in across our private network and so we
want to be able to support the telco of
your choice as you tie in so we've got a
building we got some fiber running to it
what else do we need we need electricity
right
and we don't want just a little bit of
electricity we want a lot of electricity
and we want it redundant and so we'll
have electricity that comes into this
zone from two different directions we'll
have one from provider a and one from
provider b
and then in case we have problems with
that electricity we've also got to have
generators
because if the power goes out we can't
just shut the data center down we still
have to generate electricity so we're
gonna have generators outside the
building we have to have enough
generating capacity to run everything
that's inside and in addition to those
generators
in order to bridge the gap between when
the power goes off and the generators go
on we have huge ups systems ups is an
uninterruptible power supply and those
ups systems are sized to get us 15 to 20
minutes between when the power comes off
and the generators come all the way
online now in practice we don't need
anywhere near that much time but it's
just a good thing to have so we've got
our power we've got our internet what
comes next well we need the compute and
the storage right
we've got the network well the outside
part of it we need the compute and we
need the storage so inside this data
center
we have rows of servers
and in these rows
our racks and in each rack are up to 43
servers in addition to the servers that
are on those rows we also have all of
the network gear the switches the
routers the hardware firewall devices
hardware load balancers
so all of the equipment what you think
of is the magic that is the underlying
layer of the cloud that is all in these
rows
and then the last piece that we have is
arguably the most important specifically
depending on region
and that's going to be i'm going to put
that over here that's our air
conditioning
because what's the point of having a
data center with all of this compute
storage and network capacity in it if
you can't keep it cool so we've got air
conditioning over here keeping
everything cool it's blowing cold air
into the coal aisles we're ducting the
hot air out of the hot aisles to get rid
of it
and so this is an availability zone this
is one a z
so
get back to our original question what
is an mzr
well in mzr a multi-zone region is a
single geography so a single area like
dallas fort worth or frankfurt or london
where we will have three or more
availability zones and so
we're gonna have availability zone one
availability zone two
and availability zone three one
two
three again each of these is physically
distinct from the others and we try and
put some geographical separation in them
anywhere from oh five or so kilometers
up to about 25 kilometers distance
between them
and so not only do they have physical
distance but we also make sure that they
are in geographically separate fault
profiles so if we're an area that is
active seismically we want to be sure
that they don't share common seismic
faults if we're in an area that has
flooding risks we want to be sure that
they're not all sitting in the same
flood plain
if we're in a politically unstable area
we want to be sure that they each have
their own security posture so we've got
our three zones now we have to
interconnect them all now let's use a
different color to interconnect we're
going to interconnect them like this
so we have all of this interconnection
this guarantees that if you've got a
workload that is running in zones one
and three you can keep them in sync but
we're not done i talked earlier about
customers that want to come in and they
want to bring their fiber to us they
don't just want to come in over a vpn
they want a dedicated mpls circuit or
something like that so in addition to
our three zones we are also going to
have two
network points of presence and i'm going
to call these a
and b
a network point of presence or network
pop or a network hotel
is a place where a lot of fiber comes
together fiber from companies that lease
it individually
fiber from the telcos fibers from the
provider but the fiber comes in here
these are the main connection points now
in some ibm cloud mzr locations we're
going to co-locate our network hotel in
with the data center and other ones
they're disparate but each of these
locations
is also going to be fully interconnected
with the data centers because again we
have to have as much redundancy as
possible we don't want any single
problem to take out a workload so
this is the construct the multi-zone
region now
the last question is
why would you care about a multi-zone
region why does this matter and so this
is we're gonna we're going to get into
the specifics of running highly
available cloud native workloads because
this is a different construct than how
you did it on premise back in the day
so a cloud workload that is run highly
available
let's get our data centers back up here
again so we've got one
two
and three
in a cloud native architecture you never
run in just a single zone unless you
have to and sometimes there are good
reasons that you have to some ibm cloud
locations only have one zone that's
called a single zone region and there
are lots of good reasons for that but
we're going to focus on the multi-zone
architecture so
let's say that your workload your
primary
is going to be zone one right so if
you've got
a little guy over here
and he's surfing your website on his
laptop and typing away and all that
his actual requests the request
transmission themselves
are going to be coming in
over the public internet
into
zone one
now
it's going to get processed here
data is going to get passed back what
happens if something goes wrong that
could be a power outage that could be
some sort of a natural disaster a flood
a hurricane
it could be anything that goes wrong
that could cause data center one or
availability zone one to come offline
well if your architecture is correct you
aren't using just one you have a load
balancer involved you're gonna use one
and two or one and three or one two and
three so instead of going directly to
one let's say that that connection then
fails because you've got some redundancy
in it says oh this one fell offline now
instead of going to one
no more
now we're gonna go to two
and that's gonna be the location of
where we're gonna do the computes the
app that serving up the data for the app
that you've written whatever it may be
likewise if there's a problem at two it
goes offline that's okay because you've
already got your redundancy so it's
going to start going to three
this cloud native highly available
architecture is key to a successful
cloud deployment if you are not running
your production apps highly available in
two zones you are going to get yourself
into trouble now if you have additional
questions about how to engage in this
kind of architecture we would love to
help you out please reach out to your
ibm sales team go check out the ibm
cloud architecture center we have lots
of documentation on how to build your
workload so that you don't have to worry
about a failure in any particular zone
you're set up for native success in a
cloud native manner
thank you so much for your time today if
you have any questions please drop us a
line below if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please do
like and subscribe and let us know
and don't forget you can grow your
skills and earn a badge with ibm cloud
labs which are free browser-based
interactive kubernetes labs that you can
find more information on by looking
below thanks again